so um today we're asking people the
question people in London so since women
have the right to choose right we have
the right to get an abortion for free in
London up to six months should men have
the right to a financial abortion where
they can sign off their rights and they
don't have to pay child support I
believe that's yes I believe a yes to
that I believe
but you you need to figure out like a
tighter schedule for how it should work
like okay
um if you're not married like if you're
gonna have the baby you need the guy to
sign off for before a certain time that
he's going to accept all the financial
responsibilities for it and then make it
binding
um I think you'd have to kind of have a
real set structure to it and I think if
you like
he goes yes yes and he goes actually you
know what
I've said yes and I'm going to change my
mind I don't think it should be like
that but I think you should definitely
like
have to sign something prior to prior to
the birth
why
why do you think we have child support
because why and because in my head it's
like why are I as a woman entitled to a
man's money
a soup based
I personally think it's a lot of it's
based around the perception of it's
quite a sexist and the perception of the
woman is the weaker sex the woman is not
as able to earn as much that the woman's
always if they're manipulated into a
situation of having a child so it's
their sort of support on that level I
mean when you get to it it
it's kind of I'm yeah it's kind of a bit
unbalanced I agree I agree I think it's
very unbalanced do you um so do you
think abortion should be legal at all
yeah I think I think it should be I
think it should be I mean I I can always
say it as a guy on some level I have
benefited from it
in different ways on certain levels
whether it being someone you know when I
was much much younger you know someone
got pregnant and I think it's wow if I
think back now if that person had a
child and have been tied to them for 18
plus years it wouldn't have worked out
well for me
um so I think it should be legal but I
definitely think they should now as I'm
getting older and realizing there should
be a lot more education about it a
little bit more about some of the facts
of it but I definitely think it should
be always a choice when do you think
abortion should be legal up to to be
honest as a guy I I just don't know I've
not got like a set like right it should
be there's this particular date on the
timeline for it I'm you know I'm not I
don't know on a woman from a woman's
personal choice I don't get that
involved I mean obviously when it's like
to the point of like nine months I'm not
gonna say oh yeah week before yeah it's
yeah whip it out and get rid of it but
you know what's legal in the UK up to
six months yes you just told me yeah you
just told me I mean to be honest it was
never really in my mind like at my level
of awareness of when the when the
deadline was I think I remember it got
extended maybe 10 15 years ago got
lengthened out but yeah did you know the
earliest child to survive a pregnancy is
21 weeks and uh so and right now it's
legal up to 24.
I did not know that
I didn't know that no and did you know
that 40 of women that have had abortions
um are 40 of women getting an abortion
have had two or more abortions in the
past
once again another another statistic I
did I didn't know I'm just curious if
that like changes your opinion on it at
all I'm like when it should be legal it
doesn't really change my opinion but I
definitely feel that both sides should
be have been allowed to
um the uh voice their concerns I'm not
like if someone feels it should be
illegal they should be shouted down I
can I can see where a lot of people are
coming from I mean the the whole concept
of like birth control and abortion has
definitely changed the Dynamics between
men and women
um what gives all the power to women
right yeah on a reproductive level I
mean yeah there's a lot of
responsibility but it can well a lot of
power but it comes without the shame
a lot of the issues of the past because
there's always a potential for women to
become pregnant and have a baby but you
know if you went back 60 so 60 plus
years ago there's a huge aspect of Shame
and social social conventions and
everything else I think I think it's
what people expect of a single movie
single motherhood is a little bit skewed
from what I've seen now from what from
what I've seen women go through well
it's looks like it's almost incentivized
to be a single mother because you get
money for it you get money for it either
through child support or from the
government yeah so it's like if you
incentivize something more people are
going to do it oh yeah for sure I mean
there's always the Trope of
if a single mother be able to get more
easily get like um flat from the council
for housing or in America it was like if
in the housing projects it was is much
easier but now it's gone from being that
just a perception of easier to it's been
rebranded to the strong independent
single mother
um I mean I personally think that
raising a child is a team sport I mean
you you know ideally you need you need
both parents actively participating to
have a full well-rounded child what lies
would you see it like what lies would
you like to see in the future that would
advocate for a man I'd like to see
compulsory DNA tests okay
um because just there seems to be a lot
not a lot I don't know the active
statistics but I think that would help
to clear up situations where you know
someone's getting pregnant and then they
think you know what the guy I was
sexually attracted to and I've actually
become pregnant too is not as stable as
candidate number candidate B who I can
say hey we've had a baby and I can sort
of tie down because you hear these
stories and it's you know it gets scary
so there's that I think the contractual
situation be much clearer I think
because then
you can guarantee a certain level of
Rights because I've heard so many
stories for male friends where the
relationship was going well at the start
things have broken down then maybe
they've not got married don't have no
real parental rights over for the child
so if there's like the the whole
agreement situation beforehand then
there'd be an agreement already
regarding
um visitation or just parental rights
well I've heard I have a friend named
Sarah and he advocates for marriage
contracts that go for a certain amount
of time and you can renegotiate
yeah I mean I do remember my friend's
sister's husband said oh you know
marriage is like a business and I think
it was more like different people in the
partnership take different roles
but I can see how that could I could see
how that could work but an also as well
and it's like sure
it makes it quite cold the whole aspect
of a bit of contract but then I could
see the logic behind it the logic is
strong do you think the more our society
has focused on love as opposed to duty
that marriage has broken down because of
that yeah because it's
well yeah I mean I guess I mean my
parents are like well my my dad's passed
my mum's 76 and you hear the story and a
lot of it's Duty like making things work
they eventually they got divorced and
then they came back together but I think
a lot of people's versions of Love is
more lust uh or infatuation and it's
gonna pass there's not a case of right
we've been brought together we've got
we've built something together let's
make this last it's like oh I'm tired of
you now I'm fed up with this let's keep
it moving but you've got now you brought
kids into the world it's Dude Love is
overtaken Duty by a long shot I think
Disney has played a lot into it because
people think it's like supposed to be
this electric like fairy tale sort of
thing yeah I mean I can't I can't I
can't speak for obviously I can't speak
for women yeah of course but you know if
for guys I think because obviously not
obviously I thought guys more logic
based quite often and they're kind of a
bit more pragmatic whereas you know
we're talking to lots of different women
over time it does feel they're looking
for that spark and then you're like well
look you just took it away you want a
family you're looking for a spark but
you're 39.
well you know I mean I mean you know I
don't want to be horrible I mean there's
there's the chance she loves a Young
Person's game
I think love and love being loving is a
human condition but the whole but we're
living in that realm of possibility it's
it's more practical it's easier when
you're younger actually I think it's to
be to be really fair when I was younger
I didn't have any idea understanding of
it I think now it's much it's much
easier for a guy on certain levels
because you have more time because for a
woman it's when you know when I was 21
and the girl was like really hustling me
like what do you want to do where you
were going to be young like relax was
now I can look back at it and go [__]
she had a point because for her her
window her time her window time is very
very short I mean 90 of our eggs are
gone by 30. yeah I heard that I've had
that conversation with a girl she was
like 30 33 and she got it but you know
as a guy and most girls don't really
want to have that conversation yeah you
know women leave 70 to 80 percent of the
time in marriages and 90 of their
college educated so it's really not the
men that are breaking up the home it's
the women yeah I kind of knew that
already and I've seen it already I mean
because I used to work quite a lot for
in The Nightlife industry so I've people
I've known for over years and years and
I've seen their patterns and it it does
make your question because there's not
many guys who are like yeah jumping up
and down wanting like I really need to
get married and have this romantic
wedding and everything else I've always
I've always thought about and then they
concede and they do it because they
thought that's what they need to access
this girl and give her what she wants
and then she gets bored or all the guys
who are stuck in situations where it's
just Barren because the the attraction's
gone yeah
well thank you so much for for sitting
down
um you're kind of red pill I don't know
if you you watch red pill content yes a
little bit a little bit I'm bits and
pieces I mean it's I think to be honest
some of it is just
it's just like what was never really
allowed to be said if you're if you've
got some experience yes but you know I
was kind of
um like to still maintain some
compassion
well thank you very much appreciate it